[Music]
hey everybody we're here to talk to you
about benchmarking today I'm Chris and
I'm Dustin and we're engineers who work
on Android toolkit stuff so first I'd
like to start off with a note we're not
here to talk about benchmarking devices
I know a lot of people out there are
probably really excited to compare a
phone a to phone B but that's not what
this talk is about this talk is about
benchmarking Android app code
specifically Kotlin and java based app
code and a little bit of NDK code too so
what is benchmarking there's probably a
couple definitions out there but for all
intents and purposes of this talk we're
talking about measuring code performance
right we want to know how much time it
takes to run some chunk of code and we
want to measure this in a way where we
can see our improvements reflected in
those measurements and of course unlike
profiling we're not running the full
application here we're looking for our
tool for rapid feedback loops we want to
iterate and quickly so you published an
app very exciting right we're gonna be
rich and famous and then your users
start writing reviews so first five out
of five stars we're doing great parts in
the eyes was this review helpful yes for
my self-esteem 500 guy five again
awesome little hesitation space
exclamation mark we're doing great and
then the inevitable one star review lag
oh you're so upset you can't even spell
it right well we've been there too and
we'd like to share what we've learned so
let's go on a benchmarking adventure
very exciting we'll start off with the
test we'll call it my first benchmark
and here's some here's an object we
might be interested in benchmarking if
you haven't seen this before this is the
jetpack work manager library and it's
basically an abstraction over async
tasks and here's a synchronous test API
we can use to measure so what's the
first thing we would might we might do
well we could get the system time and
then get this to sometime after we've
done the work subtract that out I'll put
that as a result and great we have our
smack right we're done well not quite
we'll find that as we run this over and
over again we'll get vastly varying
results and that's no good for
measurements but what if you ran it in a
loop and maybe we'll run this loop five
times and then we'll report the average
so great problem solved right there's
still a few issues here well first five
is kind of like a random magic number
and ideally we'd like to dynamically
compute this number we want to report
the result when we're ready and
confident that this number won't change
too much we're also measuring
immediately and the issue here is that
the first couple runs of some piece of
code might not be indicative of what the
real user will experience and this can
be due to code paging memory or
just-in-time compilation optimizations
and we're also including outliers so
some everything on device is a shared
resource and this can cause
complications background interference
that might cause certain runs to be much
much slower than they should be and if
we include those results our beds will
be completely off and make sure we're
not running an emulator right because
while it's very tempting to run tests in
emulator their emulators don't emulate
real-world performance so the lesson
here is that benchmarking is tricky it's
often inaccurate we're measuring the
wrong things at the wrong time right
sounds stable there's tons of variants
how many loops should we run and it's
hard to set up correctly that's worst of
all because benchmarking is a tool to
help us focus developer developer
efforts so it's hard to set up how much
time are really saving here so I'd like
to introduce the jetpack benchmark
library is out now and it's an awful one
and this is a previously internal tool
they've been working on for years but we
work really hard to get available to the
public now so we hope you guys will
enjoy it first I'm gonna go over a
little bit about what it looks like and
how might how you might use it in your
code and then we'll talk about the
internals and how we solved a lot of
these issues so jetpack benchmark it's a
tool for measuring code performance of
course thank you
we'd like to prevent common measuring
mistakes there's a lot of common
pitfalls that we've seen in the past and
we want to
pass those lessons onto you and best of
all is integrated with Android studio
who doesn't love androids to integration
right so let's jump back to our previous
example here's our here's our previous
benchmark it's four boasts and it's full
of errors but this is really only the
code that we care about the highlighted
code here about three lines so let's fix
that first we apply the benchmark rule
and then all this code becomes one
simple API call measure it repeated and
we can focus on the code that we really
care about let's check out another
example here is the database benchmark
so first let's initialize our database
with room and if you haven't seen room
before it's another jetpack library it's
just an abstraction over databases all
that matters really here is we're
initializing some object to represent
that allow us to make database queries
so first let's clear all the tables and
insert some test data create our
measuring loop and then we can measure
the code that we care about in this case
it's some kind of complex query not sure
what it is doesn't really matter but
there's an issue here depending on your
database implementation your query could
be cached right if we know that the
query results won't be changed shouldn't
we just save that result and use that in
the future instead of having to use
complex Korea all over again so what
we're gonna have to do is we have to
take this clear and insert test data
method and do it inside the loop right
every single time plus the cache so we
can measure it what we actually care
about but there's another problem here
we're now measuring more than we
actually care so what are we gonna do
well we could do the previous thing
where we take the system time before and
after maybe save that to some variable
output the result then subtract that
from our final result and then we'll
have our actual result that we care
about right well this is again very
verbose and fortunately this is a common
use case that we run into - so we've
create an API for this as well and
that's the run with timing stable block
so I know a lot of Java developers out
there are probably wondering well what
about us well of course we have Java API
as well and it's slightly different so
I'd like to go through this line by line
a lot of code has changed here so first
we have to create this get state meri we
create this benchmark state variable
and this is how the library's gonna
commit to your code when it's done we
create a while loop and call state keep
running and inside that block we can run
all the code that we want to measure if
we ever need to do any setup or
initialization we can just call this
pause timing method do our
initialization and then resume when
we're ready to measure again so that's
great I've got one more example for you
guys and it's a UI example a very
compelling case for benchmarking it
might be UI and we've designed this
library to integrate on top of existing
test infrastructure and that's because
we want you to be able to use all your
favorite tools for example the activity
test rule which is an extraction that
will help you with activity lifecycle
and all the setup you need in order to
make a UI test so we simply mark this
test as an @ UI thread test to run on
the main thread and then we get a
reference to our psych review then as
before we just create a net repeat of
loop and measure the code that we care
about in this case we're scrolling by
the height of one item so let's talk
about studio integration with studio 3.5
we're releasing a new benchmark module
template to help you get up and running
with your benchmarks so let's walk
through what adding a benchmark module
looks like so here's a typical Android
project we've got an app module and a
library module because we love
modularization and we're great
developers we right-click the project
click new module and we'll get up and
we'll get this new create this create
new module
wizard that you've probably seen before
and if you scroll the way to the bottom
you'll see this new benchmark module
icon click Next and into this little
configuration dialog you can use to
choose your module name change the
package name and we've got templates on
both Kotlin and Java based code so click
finish come back to the project right
now we have our benchmark module let's
take a look inside we've got a previous
we've got an example here benchmark here
that you can just run up and running a
similar as before except the benchmark
rule measure repeated loop and it works
out of a box you can just run it and
your result will appear directly in
studio in case we're developing locally
and you want to iterate quickly we've
also got JSON and excellent output data
will pull off from connected
instrumented tests from device on to
your host
machine and we've done this with
intention to be congested by continuous
integration tools so if you want to look
for regressions and look for
improvements you've made over time this
is a great way to do that
as with any module there's also a build
Gradle file and there's a couple things
here I'd like to point out so first
there's a bench there's a benchmark
plugin that we're going to be shipping
along with the library there's a custom
runner that extends off the Android
j-unit Runner and it's also open to be
extended in case you need to do that
we've also pre-built it with some
pre-built ProGuard rules that'll work
out of the box with a jetpack benchmark
library and of course the library itself
can't forget that very important so
let's talk about the Gradle plugin so
that's this line you saw before we apply
a plug-in line it's gonna help you pull
your benchmark reports when you run
Gradle w connected Android test or
connected check for CI and we've also
got some Gradle tasks for CPU clock
stability in there as well
the test runner that's the Android
benchmark runner it's kind of an
in-depth topic so we'll talk more about
that later but suffice to say it's got a
lot of baked in tricks to stabilize your
benchmarks we've also got program rules
and that's in this file here our
template supplies pre-configured program
rules and that's important because
program optimizes your code so you want
to make sure you're running your
benchmark in a configuration it
represents real user performance right
so we want to do this at a release
production environment possible so
that's why we bundle these rules for you
and we realize that tests generally
don't use program or r8 but this is
important for benchmarks and it's
probably why we've set it up as a
separate module so we've also included
an Android manifest here that's gonna
run with your Android tests and if you
notice here we've set two bugaboo to be
false and one this is normally enabled
by default for tests it's great because
it allows us to use things like
connecting a debugger and use all of our
favorite debugging tools and it's great
when you're testing for correctness but
it's not so great for benchmarks we've
seen before that runs have been between
0 to 80 percent slower and 80 percent is
not the number that should be that
should be worrying you it's the - it's
the range the variability here it's hard
to account for let's take a look at
example here are some benchmarks we'll
be
an ASP that we use in the jet and in the
jet pack team and along the x-axis
you'll see several different types of
benchmarks that we do along the y-axis
is normalized duration how long the
benchmark took to run blue is with
tobacco false and red is with debuggable
on and we've normalized each benchmark
benchmark by benchmark not across the
board so you'll see here indeed the DCR
lays an example that there's hardly in a
difference if you look really closely
it's like one pixel off one percent
difference right but over here in the
inflates simple benchmark there's
there's a wide there's a huge difference
here and again the hard part here is the
variability it's really hard to account
for so we want to make sure that the
optimizations and the code change we're
making are actually going to have an
impact on our users we need to make sure
it's a buggy ball is off so that leaves
me about benchmark configuration and
here I just like to give some tips that
we that we also bundled with the
template but you should definitely be
setting up your benchmarks this way so
first as before we'd like to turn off
the bug ability we also want to make
sure code coverage is false if you're
using something like jacoco this
actually modifies the Dex in order to
support what it needs to do and that's
great if you're trying to if you're
trying to get code coverage but we're in
your bank sport but when you're running
a benchmark that's not so great
of course before you like to enable
ProGuard and we currently support
library modules for alpha 1 we're really
pushing developers to a module eyes or
app this year and I'd like to wreck I'd
like to do a little shout out please
check out the how to create a modular
Android app architecture talk that was
on Tuesday so you should go find that on
YouTube it's my Florina e but what if
you forget that's the library we can do
a lot but we can't do everything
we can't just print out a device and
have you run on that write that but that
would be great
fortunately we've got warnings so we're
going to we're going to corrupt our
output and make it very visible to you
and hopefully this is something that you
can catch in your continuous integration
tests so here's an example some couple
warnings the Bugaboos before if you're
running on an emulator that's also
pretty bad if you're missing the runner
then you're not using any of our tricks
to help stabilize your benchmarks and if
you're low on battery now a surprising
thing about low on being low on battery
is that well you might expect the device
will throttle itself right I'll try and
save power however we found that on many
devices it still does this even while
it's charging so this is definitely
something you want to watch out for so
that's a bit about what the library
looks like and how you would use it and
now Chris is going to talk about how it
works all right so that was a lot of
information about what it looks like to
use the library but there's a lot of
implementation behind it to implement
all of these behaviors that Dustin was
talking about so first of all let's talk
about CPU clock specifically frequency
and how it's kind of the enemy of
stability because when you go up and
down massively you change results and
you make it very hard to discover
regressions and improvements so from the
perspective of benchmarking there are
really two problems that CPU clocks
introduced to us and the first is
ramping um clocks generally start out
low when the device isn't doing anything
and then once once work is scheduler is
scheduled
they will ramp slowly over time in order
to get to a high performance mode on the
other side of this though when the
device gets hot because it's been
running for a long time it will dive the
clocks will dive quickly and you'll get
terrible performance so both of these
are problems let's talk about them one
at a time so first ramping clocks clocks
will generally increase under load and
what we've seen is that this takes about
100 milliseconds so here we have a clip
of a little sis trace here and the only
thing that's important to note is the
clock frequency at the bottom versus
when the work stop started on the top at
the very beginning of the trace you see
time equals zero milliseconds the
frequency is 300 megahertz incredibly
slow a frequency that most of your app
code is never going to see
however after about 75 milliseconds you
see that we go all the way up to 2.5 6
gigahertz if we were measuring in
between these two times that would be
bad however the solution for this is
actually pretty simple benchmark just
runs warm up in order to account for
this
so we spin the measurement loop for 250
milliseconds before we ever start
measuring and then we only start
measuring once tape timing stable
this also has the nice side effect of
handling the Android runtimes
just-in-time compilation by the time
that your performance numbers are
stabilizing JIT has stabilized as well
you're seeing performance that's
corresponding to what your your user
would see in a in a frequently hot code
path so that was ramping but diving is a
much bigger problem when the device gets
hot the clocks dive quickly and this is
called thermal throttling generally the
CPU will lower its frequency once it
gets to a very high level because it
wants to avoid overheating and damaging
the chip unexpectedly though this this
this can happen unexpectedly though and
massively affect performance while we're
running our benchmarks so take a look at
this sample where I'm just taking a
pretty simple benchmark it's just doing
a tiny bit of matrix math in the loop um
and at the beginning I'm getting
relatively stable performance over the
first minute or so it looks pretty
stable e at 2 milliseconds all as well
but less than a minute in performance
becomes terrible look at that
less than a minute listen two minutes in
we are up to three and a half times the
performance that we expect however the
device runs at this low clock for a
little while it cools down and it's back
down okay well we're good now right no
we're still doing the work so over the
result of this like five minute test we
have thermal throttling taking us up and
down and making these results pretty
terrible right like we can't extract a
whole lot of information from these
because we are dynamically going between
two and seven milliseconds we can't
trust these measurements so our solution
to throttling we found is is different
per device because we have different
tools that we can use in different
configurations so the first solution to
two thermal throttling is the simplest
lock clocks what if we could just set
the clock frequency well unfortunately
this this is ideal but this requires
route this is not a great solution for
the average person because although we
can set it to a minimum a medium
frequency this this will keep it from
thermal throttling because you know the
my sandals medium frequency just fine we
do provide a great plugin for for you
though if you do have a device that that
that is routed simply gradle w lock
clocks and your device is locked but
requiring route though is really not a
general solution we don't recommend it
so what else do we have well there was
this API added in Android in window dot
sis tet sustained performance mode and
this is was originally designed for VR
and for games but it's incredibly
appealing for benchmarks this is because
it lowers the max clocks specifically to
solve this problem prevent throttling
perfect right and it also works on GPUs
as well as CPU so it's even useful if
you're wanting to do rendering
benchmarking say if you're a game
however it comes along with a lot of
difficulties it's designed for VR not
for headless benchmarks so first of all
it requires an activity running with a
flag set it also has two separate modes
if it thinks that you're a single
threaded versus multi-threaded and it's
also only supported on some N+ devices
so let's talk through each of these
maybe we can solve some of this so the
first is the activity flag and we in
order to solve this problem we actually
just launch an activity for you around
any headless test we inject an activity
that launches any time that we might
need to use the set sustained
performance mode so that it's up at all
times we set this flag also on any
activities that you launched so if
you're doing a UI test like Dustin was
showing before with the recyclerview
that gets this property as well and it
works together with activity test rule
and activity scenario so you don't have
to worry about adapting to this new
model and in addition it also calls it
out in the UI of the test while it's
running it pops up there says hey I'm in
sustain set sustained performance mode
now okay so we've got a way to to solve
the problem of needing the flag but how
do we handle the two different modes so
so first let's describe what these are
the sets of same performance mode can
either operate in a single or a
multi-threaded mode either that means
you have one your single threaded
application so we can use we could
probably use one core at max frequency
all right or your multi-threaded in
which case it will set all of the cores
to
lower-frequency ought to prevent
throttling let's find for a game but
we're trying to run potentially
different benchmarks with different
threading models and switching between
these modes will create inconsistency so
what do we do about this problem like
how do we make we really like to just
pick the multi-threaded mode that's the
lower of both that sounds good but how
do we force that well the way that we do
this is in our android benchmark runner
win sustained performance mode is in use
we create a new thread and this thread
spins and this is a really strange way
to do this but it turns out that this is
actually a pretty efficient way to to
force us into a multi-threaded mode and
it gives us that incredibly sustained
performance that we were looking for we
are also you know set a knit thread name
for it so if you see this in a trace you
understand what's going on and we do the
best we can we set thread priority to be
the lowest possible so that it
interferes with your test minimally but
here's a look at what that looks like in
systrace so on the top there you can see
clock frequency and over the time of the
benchmark running when the test starts
the activity launches BAM were suddenly
locked to half clocks perfect we're not
going to thermal throttle in that
configuration once the test is done the
activity finish finishes and then the
clocks are free to ramp back up slowly
over time so we talked about how we
solved the issue with having an activity
running with a flag set we talked about
the two different modes but we still
have this last issue this is only on
some n plus devices so you can check
whether this is supported on a specific
device by calling power manager is the
same the same performance mode supported
by the way this is supported for
anything that is VR certified so you
have that however in the firebase test
lab for example 11 out of the 17 nougat
plus OS device combos have support for
it so it's not terribly hard to find
something that you can use like this for
CI but again this is still not a general
solution this requires platform support
that isn't available on every phone so
our final solution to this problem at
the very end here is the red dot sleep
the simplest solution we don't have many
devices aren't rooted many devices don't
have sustained performance mode so we
use the Red Dot sleep so what we do here
is we use a we detect a slowdown in
between every benchmark by running a
little tiny mini benchmark to see if the
device has started thermal throttling if
if it does we throw away the current
benchmark data and we sleep to let the
device cool down so we saw this previous
slide how performance was oscillating
all over the place and we couldn't get
stable numbers out of this well in this
particular case our device doesn't have
root so we can't use clock clocks it
can't use that sustained performance
mode not available okay can't use that
so we have to fall back on thread dot
sleep so let's see how that actually
performs in this graph that is a lot
better it is it is just completely flat
and if you see here we have standard
deviation for the two different
approaches for the default we've got
2.25 milliseconds and for thread not
sleep if you look closely point O two
milliseconds massively more stable much
more consistent performance but there
was a sacrifice with this so because we
were sleeping every time that we
detected thermal throttling it takes
longer to run this one takes about eight
minutes the original takes about four
and a half so in summary our solution
for thermal strategy does have three
different steps and we use the best
solution for your device that's
available for your particular phone so
clocks are one thing but what about
background interference what about other
things running on your device so first
of all you have to ask am I in the
foreground so if you're not something
else is and this is important to think
about in the context of performance
tests generally run if they're if they
don't have UI with the on say top of the
launcher because there's nothing to
launch nothing to display however this
means that the OS thinks the launcher
right now is the important app when
you're running in the background
say for instance behind the launcher
that means you get a lot of sources of
potential performance interference
you might have a law live wallpaper
rendering you might have home screen
widgets updating you could have the
launcher doing hot word detection or
other miscellaneous work that you don't
know about the status bar is probably
repainting every now and then with like
a notification coming up the clocks
changing Wi-Fi whatever and starting a
new --get it's possible for devices to
have a foreground exclusive core a core
that is only available to be used by the
foreground application you just can't
touch that if you're in the background
so we want to jump to the foreground and
we actually have a solution for this
already right we have our old activity
remember this guy so this also solves
this particular problem and that's why
we use this in all benchmark
configurations regardless of whatever
your clocks are um the benchmark keeps
this activity in the foreground at all
times unless you have your own in order
to guarantee that you can use all cores
with minimum Ritter rendering
interference from whatever's going on
underneath you but there's another
important source of background
interference and that is contention so
everything on the device um from CPU to
disk is a shared resource and if your
benchmark is being let's say kicked off
of a CPU because of some conflict with
another another task if you're accessing
disk and system services at the same
time that someone else is or if somebody
has random background work happening for
instance like the system doing something
an app background job something along
those lines
those can create contention so for
example if we were running our benchmark
and warm up just finished so we're just
right about to start taking measurements
however we have this other process here
that's about to start doing some work
our first few loops are fine but then
the other process kicks in and starts
running as well all the sudden we see oh
well actually some of these loops are
just giving me flat-out bad numbers not
very useful numbers that overlap with
this background work some of these runs
are still totally fine but some of them
aren't so that's why we have this idea
of measure twice report once and by
twice I of course mean many times we
will measure we will measure
we will measure several loops and
understanding that most contention is
for a short duration we we can ignore it
we can ignore those those loops that are
most likely to have hit contention so
what we do in fact is that we report and
track the minimum number observed not
the average because the average is
susceptible to contention this way the
number that we report by the
benchmarking library is immune to tiny
little hiccups that happen every now and
then and my otherwise interfere with
your numbers all right so let's talk
about how to go about using this library
so the first thing that we want to
recommend is don't benchmark everything
start with tracing start with profiling
tools maybe you have measurement going
on on real user devices that tell you
some particular part is slow well that's
a good place to start pinch mark what
you know is slow so that you can iterate
on it and improve it we generally
recommend benchmarking synchronous
blocks because these are the easiest to
measure and these are the easiest to
improve over time so if you're measuring
something that the single-threaded is
much more likely to be stable and
isolated from other tasks there's no
thread hopping that means you're taking
the scheduler entirely out of the mix
and that way for instance you might
measure UI separately from network
separately from database and rendering
we also generally recommend fairly small
blocks on these are faster to run um and
here we've been probably less than 50
milliseconds
however the loop itself only has around
a 6 nanosecond overhead and this is like
running on a fairly old device at half
clocks um so you can measure really
small amounts of work with a
benchmarking library another important
thing to remember is that the
benchmarking library is primarily for
hot code because we run all of your your
code with warm up and we run it in a
loop that probably means that the code
inside is going to be JIT it now that's
great if it's something like work that's
done by your recyclerview but if it's
only run once in a while by your app
it's not as likely to get JIT it so be
very careful when you're benchmarking
startup
we generally recommend to only look only
benchmark the code that is inside of a
loop during startup so that it is more
likely to to be measured correctly
another thing to keep in mind is to be
aware of caches that might be anywhere
in your code or even in someone else's
code so here's a simple example of a
benchmark where we access a file and
check whether it exists maybe we observe
that this took a couple of milliseconds
during startup the problem is that the
OS is going to take this and it's going
to know that nothing has changed and
just serve you a cached value every time
the benchmark is going to be very
different than the behavior at startup
so be aware of this you can sometimes
take measures to create a different
create things differently for example
like Dustin should at the beginning with
the database another thing to consider
is potentially avoid over parameterizing
so correctness tests it's really easy to
say sweep over five different variables
recognize that okay overall 4,000 of
these tests none of them failed great
you get a pass that is a much harder
task for benchmarking because we're
getting something that isn't a simple
pass/fail more data can be more
difficult to deal with we recommend to
start targeting benchmarks at real-world
parameters instead of maybe going as
enthusiastically towards
parameterization as you might during a
unit test one thing I really want to
re-emphasize though that Dustin
mentioned before is please do not
compare devices this library is not
designed to compare the performance of
one device versus another we're really
focused on comparing code whether that's
framework code whether that's app code
on the same device same operating system
version the library optimizes for
stability it will have some factor of
difference that can vary from device to
device over what you see in a benchmark
versus what you see in reality and
that's because we do not account for
real world clocks for example if the
user touches down on their device starts
generally the clocks will ramp if a de
beaut user uses their device for a
while and it gets hot and at thermal
throttles it performs poorly the clocks
go down none of that is accounted for in
the benchmarking library and that's why
we don't recommend comparing devices
with our library so you might be
wondering okay how do I go about in
integrating this into my CI so there are
different tiers of adoption that you can
that you can start with to look at
exactly how deeply you want to get into
benchmarking the first is quick and
local it's very reasonable to do a trace
write a benchmark and measure the
performance make a change check in that
change without having to monitor the
performance over time and detect
regressions and in general this is
because unlike correctness tests
benchmarks usually get better because
you're deleting code now that said if
you can monitor them over time
potentially manually that's a totally
reasonable way to go and that's that's
even better
um but we want to recognize that there's
still value in manual monitoring of
benchmarks even if you don't have
regression testing because a automatic
regression detection because automatic
regression text detection is a complex
problem however if you do want to go all
the way to that point and we recommend
it it is it is just very it is something
to to recognize that it's not as simple
as detecting when does my benchmark go
down by say 1% because there's going to
be all sorts of times where it flakes a
little bit it goes down a little bit you
make a trade-off for one benchmark
versus another or you check in a feature
that just absolutely needs to make this
one code path slightly slower so if
you're if you're prepared to receive
emails for all those things by all means
just something to keep in mind all right
and so let's go through a few closing
notes we do have as Justin mentioned
early earlier an indie case ample that
shows how to use some of our
infrastructure together with C++ code
that's available on our Android
performance github repository and it
actually wraps the existing Google
benchmark C++ library to get numbers
directly from infrastructure that you
might already be using for C++
benchmarking
it captures the results together with
Java and Catalan benchmarks in our file
output and it applies all of our Android
specific tricks regarding stabilizing
clocks so now just to mention that this
is actually a fairly old library so why
haven't you heard of it before well this
library has been around since about 2016
used inside of the Android platform and
we use it all over the place we use it
for text for graphics for views for
resources for sequel light for
optimizing all of these different
components but for a long time it's been
very difficult to use externally because
we kind of needed you to have a rooted
device to run this on and that's easy
that that's easy for a platform
developer much harder for an app
developer but more recently we have
overhauled it for non rooted devices
we've switched over to Kotlin which gave
us some really nice benefits in terms of
function inlining for that measurement
loop and allow us to minimize overhead
so now libraries such as room navigation
and slices all use our benchmarking
library to make improvements so here's
an example from a from from the platform
from a couple of years ago I think this
was an O when we noticed that hey
toggling the visibility of a relatively
large tree of views was kind of
expensive so this was our CI over the
process of checking in a few changes so
at the beginning modifying these views
took 300 micro 302 50 microseconds and
we checked in an optimization for how
outlines were changed when views were
stored and so it went down a little bit
and we actually realized like okay most
of the work here is actually in view dot
invalidate it's doing a lot of work that
it doesn't need to anymore in a modern
hardware accelerated pipeline so we
checked in a complete overhaul of that
and of course we quickly reverted it
because it broke the world but we did we
did learn a lot of little of things that
we needed to change along that path and
after we were able to check that back in
we were able to get a total improvement
of 100% of 50% of taking that view
toggling from point three five
milliseconds per say 64 views or
whatever down to half of that which is a
huge improvement and we did this all
before we had automatic regression
testing
so in summary here we've seen through
all of these tricks that we talked about
benchmarking is a really complex problem
it's really hard to measure accurately
it's um it's it's completely foiled by
clock instability and background
interference can be a real source of
pain when you're trying to detect
changes that's why with Jetpack
benchmarking we've provided a simple API
we bundled in all the lessons we've
learned about getting stable numbers out
of a device and the Alpha is available
now thank you so much for coming if you
if you remember only one thing D Android
comm / benchmark thank you all so much
[Music]